all right disney you have proven that
series set in the mcu
will work on disney plus let's start
getting interesting
hey folks so today i am gonna pitch my
ideas for
five mcu series that should be on disney
plus
i need these i'm gonna say we all need
them but i know i need them
now this was actually harder for me to
put together than i would have initially
thought because the big one that i
wanted more than anything else
they're already doing you go way way
back to this
channel to i think it was my very first
conversation that i had with
paul and ryan and we talked about what
future projects we'd like to see from
marvel
i said i wanted she-hulk and i said
i wanted her being a lawyer can i be as
prescient now
we'll see so here's my pitch for five
ideas of shows that i think
could be really good on disney plus so
these are in more or less
likelihood order so starting with number
five
howard the duck first of all it'd be
nice just to get the taste of that movie
out of my mouth
now obviously howard as a character has
already been introduced
into the mcu we've seen him now three
times if i've got my count right
both guardians of the galaxy films that
are out as well
as end game in a blinking you'll miss it
appearance when everybody shows up
towards the end so
he's been established and we know he's
there some might argue well just do a
movie the thing is though
given the reputation of the howard the
duck movie and given that his
appearances have been very jokey i
think it's pretty unlikely that disney's
gonna shove the money behind it to do
a full-scale film for this guy however
i think he's better suited to an
episodic series anyways
howard the duck by design was always
meant to be
satirical to make fun of things in pop
culture or sometimes even political
things
he's a talking duck for crying out loud
you can't get too super serious so he's
much much better
for poking fun at things and just having
a laugh
which honestly marvel could use to have
a laugh
at themselves also i'll note
howard has had a tendency to be
dimension jumping at times throughout
his history so
if they wanted to have him jump into an
all duck dimension
an animated dimension into one of the
alternate timelines that dr
strange saw or any number of
possibilities well
you could do it and we wouldn't be
hinging
too much cannon continuity weight on it
because
it's a freaking talking duck just go
nuts next up number four
now as i was planning this video and
coming up with these ideas
this one almost got torpedoed by
something that actually looks like it's
going to be happening
so let me say what i want to do say
what's been announced and then sort of
explain why i'm still going to pitch
this anyway
what i want to do is i want a series
about
ao and the dora melange now
since i initially came up with this idea
it has been announced that there is
going to be some sort of
wakanda series on disney plus and that
the character of akoye
who is the absolute head of the
dormilage will be appearing
does that mean that they're basically
already doing my idea
not necessarily because the indications
are with the show as
with the very little that we currently
understand which
isn't much but from what can currently
be discerned it is a story
about wakanda i'm not actually looking
to
pitch something that is about not that
that's a bad idea it's a great idea
i'm down for it but i'm more picking up
on the idea from having seen
ayo and the dora milage show up in the
falcon and the winter soldier
because there they are moving about
they are engaging in missions away from
wakanda
the dora milaji have jurisdiction
wherever the dora milari find
themselves to be i kind of want to see
wakandan black ops i want to see what
kind of situations the dorm elijah gets
sent
out into the world to deal with because
it in some way affects wakanda
i want to see the situations they find
themselves in i want to see
how they take things out i want to see
them take on a foe
that is a good proper match for them
because they have a tendency to
dominate a lot of fights that's not a
criticism i actually kind of love that
fact
but i really would love to see the build
of like just seeing them work
efficiently as a team
and then over time see them start to
come up against a threat
that is really going to test them and
push them to their limits and give them
a
real proper challenge what could that
threat be i
i honestly don't know i don't know black
panther
lore and backstory well enough to really
float a suggestion on that
but i'm sure there's plenty of stuff to
go with
i mean on a wilder potential pitch
you could have wakanda starting to get
interference from latvia
and they go in there to try and figure
out what's going on and end up running
into
dr victor von doom and you could
introduce him that way
they definitely won't do that but i mean
like i'm saying there's room
you can figure it out okay for this next
one i don't even really have a solid
premise but like i know who the
characters i want
are and that is jimmy darcy and monica
that trio of characters from one
division because when they were together
in the same scene i
loved them so much they bounced off each
other
wonderfully they had great on-screen
chemistry as a trio of characters and i
just i just want more
and which one of you is the sassy best
friend there's no time for you to
diminish your colleagues
now we already know they're going to be
doing more stuff with monica
she is going to be showing up in captain
marvel 2
and i suspect they'll probably find
other stuff to do with her besides
but the thing is the three of them
together
wonderful chemistry i loved seeing them
bounce off each other
as they pitch things throw things out
there have each other's back
give some pushback challenge each other
they just had a really
good dynamic those three and i want to
see them do more stuff
as the easy go-to pitch
have monica getting sent out for stuff
related to
sword cause obviously the guy who was
running the thing he's gone
he got arrested um but have her request
i'm gonna work with jimmy i'm gonna work
with darcy
that's the team she requests that's the
team we see her
go out and be with going out on things
that
are relevant to the mandate of sword
which they need to
clarify a little bit because it's
different from what it was in the comics
in the series it got labeled as the
sentient weapon observation and response
division
so that gives us some ideas of what they
could be going out doing but i just want
to see these three work together
i want to see darcy going in like being
the tech person being the one you know
with the more brainy end of things
i want to see jimmy using his ground
level street experience as an fbi
officer to
have that other aspect to how they
approach things and i want to see monica
go in and
mop up whatever they have to deal with
and really get a
grounding in her newfound powers now if
this were to ever happen it would be
after
however she is going to be used in
captain marvel 2 and obviously that
might
shake up or make impossible this concept
depending on what
things do or don't happen there but i
just
more of these three i just please please
please okay for this next one we're
gonna step outside of characters that
have in fact already been introduced
into the mcu
and i'm gonna talk about one who i just
want
to see and experience and be
with in film very very much
i mean film tv in this case
squirrel girl now if you
have watched the marvel rising animated
series
films things we have had a squirrel girl
appear and she was pretty good
i did like her but i want
to see squirrel girl done properly in
live action and we almost had it
there was going to be a new warriors tv
show and she was going to be included
as part of that it got cancelled i don't
think they even got as far as a pilot
but squirrel girl needs
to be on television now if you've never
read the unbeatable squirrel girl
kicks butts eats nuts she just
loves absolutely loves being a superhero
and yes her superpowers are basically
agility of a squirrel
can talk to squirrels has really sharp
teeth
and that's about it plus the tail the
tail isn't really a superpower
necessarily but
it's really cool and she's just bubbly
and fun and loves what she does
and more often than not when she defeats
somebody she doesn't defeat them by
kicking their butt she defeats them by
honestly sometimes just confusing them
sometimes coming to understand what it
is they're doing and talking them
out of it she has a long history of
making friends with the people that she
goes into fights with
she's just so much wonderful bubbly
adorable
fun she is the light the brightness
the shining star that i need more of in
my life i need more of in my
entertainment
please please
let me have squirrel girl and finally
number one this one no chance is gonna
happen
partly because the idea is kind of nuts
but
more because the people that it would
involve they would never
agree to do it not as a regularly
scheduled thing but
think about it for a minute a series
about
the asgardian actors if you're not sure
what i'm referring to think back to thor
ragnarok
where loki is pretending to be odin and
is watching a
performance supposedly of previous
events
that is what i'm talking about i want a
show
following them as they travel not just
asgard but
other realms performing for everything
from
local street corners to uh royalty
and in palaces and just being not
necessarily
caught up in but present for craziness
think if i'm going to get a little
highfalutin about it think about
a series that follows the players from
rosencrantz and guildenstern are dead
except they're as guardians now why
won't this happen aside from the fact
that i don't think this would
just as a concept would ever get
greenlit like two of the people
uh who appeared in that were matt damon
and sam neil and apparently
these characters are gonna come back in
thor love and thunder
with the addition of melissa mccarthy
who's going to be playing the actress
who's portraying hella in some kind of
recreation so like
they're not going to get these actors in
for a series but
as a performer as an actor as someone
with that
those kinds of ambitions and with a
history in it i mean not
professionally but i tried it didn't
work out but
to see that exploring just watch them
travel and just try and
earn their keep entertain an audience
and just be around for insanity like
especially if you get them set up in
royal settings and there's all this
entry going on they're like we're just
trying to put a
show on can we just get paid and go on
stage and get out of here
i personally i would have a lot of fun
with that
i might be the only one on the planet
who would have a lot of fun with that
but i would have a lot of fun with it
and if they ever do it
i want credit or you know you could just
um give me a part and i take that too so
those are my ideas for
five mcu series that i would like to see
and i think the world needs
but what'd you think of these pitches do
you have any pitches you want to throw
out there whatever your thoughts are
drop something down the comments let's
talk about it
i have a patreon that is how i pay my
bills there are rewards for
every single tier of support these
include things like early access to
videos and of course names in the
credits which you'll be seeing
very very shortly if not already and in
addition to that there's youtube
memberships which gives you
unique emojis to use during live chats
and streams
if you're not able to do that the likes
share subscribe those help me out they
help combat the algorithm and keep it
from burying me
hopefully but even if you're not uh up
for doing that
it's okay i'm not gonna tell you what to
do end of the day
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]